a lifetime has passed since the horrific  events of Taco Tuesday our lives  suspended into chaos this new life has  toughened and hardened but  two copies please one black one with  just a touch of cream in 25 sugars  Wow toughen most of us I wake up in the  morning morning good morning super  babies and it you've gotta stop  pretending everything is awesome  it isn't yeah I get it and that's why  I've cultivated a totally hard-edged  side that's super tough and what is it  up to  no but that beat is pretty fresh  [Music]  [Music]  it's like it knows our every move weird  right special this guy was a fierce  warrior  okay well technically I did the warrior  sir so you fought a masterbuilt and hit  but and then the hapless male was the  leader here well  [Music]  hang on to your fronds planning we're  going to save Lucy and all of the other  people who are captured  [Music]  behold the sISTAR sister do not give her  the satisfaction of wooing this  [Music]  you